we might be drunk
we
might be drunk
as long as we are hanging out you know
we might be drunk raise a glass let's
talk [ __ ] head peeps wrecks and a bit
maybe drunk
we might be drunk
yeah
someone comes i posted a picture with
taylor and someone wrote a good
girlfriend really seems to care
[Laughter]
hell i don't know if we got that last
joke but that would have been fun here
we are we might be drunk we're back
we've been all over the goddamn earth
all over the country la and back up town
downtown
here we are that's why this one's coming
late so we apologize we like to get it
out on sunday but we wanted an in studio
versus a zoom yeah [ __ ] zoom it takes
the magic out of it takes the magic
again it's like phone sex versus actual
sex penetration yeah yes
exactly it is sex robot i usually say oh
that's good i think it's like a sex
robot i don't mind a sex robot yeah well
you can just really throw her around and
jizz on stuff
hit her yeah it's fun great put her face
through the glass no i'm joking
um
what a dark start to this episode it's
been a while we have a lot of pent up uh
you know something yeah yeah well you
know women always have that uh that
self-defense class where they like kick
a dummy's ass yeah i do that with the
sex robot
what's good for the goose is good for
the gander
you just have a guy leading it choke
she's turned on by all that stuff
oh yeah i've been i've been to texas
uh
texas oh you were in l.a yeah for a
night for a night in houston a night in
austin you did rogan with yeah with
shane and
it's been a whirlwind yeah they went
straight to boston then came back they
went to la now here
what about you i was in uh
i mean i've been gone for three weeks
yeah that's why we hit the back like i
mean i was doing uh i did chicago
then los angeles then denver than los
angeles then uh phoenix then los angeles
jesus then san francisco and then i came
home holy hell a lot yeah i did a show
yesterday at gramercy theater and i'm
i'm literally on
an hour of sleep last night yeah i flew
back because the only way i could make
it back from san francisco to a new york
not great routing here you know yeah
yeah san francisco you got a new york
show that night i got to take a 7 a.m
flight so i'm on with vitor and i'm like
pray there's one person left in the bump
up for first class and i'm like praying
and i got it got that lay flat seed oh
beautiful but you think it's like you're
comfortable i still can't sleep because
when you get when you have a thing that
night you got all that anxiety and
you're and you're freaking out yep yep
and you're like well i'm gonna get 30
minutes of sleep now great and then you
just did you get none yeah and those
movie selections aren't bad oh i watched
whiplash oh there you go it's a good
movie dude great movie great movie the
arms on uh jk oh my god no joke like a
cougar in phoenix
incredible yeah cougars have great arms
amazing arms they got nothing to do all
day except pick up their husbands money
all right no but phoenix has some hot
milfs
but yeah yeah no uh
phoenix is a lot of milfs oh man i
always say in phoenix there's more
breast implants than black people
that's the motto
the the slogan of phoenix should be can
i speak to your manager yeah the
difference is in phoenix they're happy
when they see one of those things
[Laughter]
i'll tell you i went to uh yeah i did
one show in phoenix and i literally get
heckled by a woman standing up
she goes she stands up and she goes i
want you to make fun of my son
and
i go what and then i i say like and
she's like a you know a pretty hot milf
woman i was like is that your mom and he
goes unfortunately and it the crowd's
like what the [ __ ] is going on and then
uh and then she he she goes it's not my
stepmom like yeah and then and then she
goes i wish
and i'm like these people want to [ __ ]
each other this is good clearly
arizona's basically alabama
but you know bigger city yeah with tan
and fake blonde yeah wow that's wild
how old was a kid i i want to say early
20s
i mean and then i asked about the
husband
i was like what about the husband she
goes he passed away oh perfect i said
doors open it's all locking in yeah i
mean jesus i mean look what has more
views than stepmom porn i know it's
number one so these kids are just being
fed that all day it's only natural this
was real mom oh i thought it was stepmom
no he said i wish she was my stepmom
yeah oh that's even weirder that's not
good wow all right now it's weird yeah
[ __ ]
oh man that's bananas yeah
yeah they're gonna [ __ ] they're gonna
[ __ ] i should say we're doing our coffee
we're doing two episodes today so
today's a coffee day
and uh the next episode will be a boozy
with the beer beer jew yeah we got the
beer juice coming back we need to we
need to recover a little cause you know
when you're on those
i have to plan the coffee buzz into the
alcohol buzz especially like i got one
hour's sleep i get to the venue and i'm
like i'm doing i'm doing a ton of coffee
at like seven yeah and then i get there
and they say what do you want in your
green room and i said pepto-bismol and
negroni
give me medicine and poison in the same
rider that's great yeah but you pushed
her i was on no sleep on thursday i did
the brea improv huge room
my management is there because it's la
so we're going to come out and support
what you're like ah i know that you mean
well but it's a nightmare they all come
in the green room it's nice but
uh it's still a lot and you're on no
sleep so you got to be on with them then
you got to do the show and they the
whole time you're on stage you're
thinking of them judging you like this
is our client you know you feel like a
racehorse a little bit like i got to
kill it and uh that was just a lot so i
can't imagine an hour i had like three
hours but an hour
yeah dude it's it's tough when you're
but then you're also like i can tell i
can power through one of these i i did
three shows the day before in san
francisco yeah you know
san francisco is a great city man great
town great city one of the one of the
jewels of the us
it's beautiful it looks european it does
the architecture's killer the hills
really help i love it yeah the water the
bay the whole thing the bridge the
seafood seafood good seafood really
seems to care
number one suicide bridge we've covered
that yeah and a lot of people they
change their mind right when they jump
right when they let go they go that was
a mistake yeah
that's gotta suck i know i have that
after like i when i used to have one
night stands right when you finished you
were like that was a mistake it was a
mistake shouldn't have done that yeah
who is this guy i have a joke about that
now how you think you think pedophiles
get that
yeah they almost get a double yeah they
might be like oh [ __ ] what was i
thinking yes because ours i mean sure
she's in a wheelchair but at least it's
legal you know the kid is not even legal
hey look at that cutie oh gary vee jeez
you guys went all out on this
and i'll tell you the funny thing that
looks great right wasn't even one of the
better meals we had this looks like a
make-a-wish
oh it gets even cuter when gary uh he
holds up a steph curry jersey for his
baby and he goes i'm gonna get one for
me too
little yeah no he's uh we had such a
good time oh amazing peter
is a great little uh road companion
great hang great guy great comic check
out his album folks
he's always up early because we're on
the road and uh you know he's got a baby
at home sure so he's just naturally up
early
always and he's always always got a text
like eight he's like breakfast i'm like
dude what do you think yeah what do you
think is going on here nobody loves the
road more than dads because like we
don't have kids so we're on the road
like oh here we go i got to do they're
like ah the sun is shining they're like
singing uh you know show tunes in the
morning because it's there's no children
there yeah they get a break yeah you're
right the wife hates him i'm sure
yeah oh yeah
it is hilarious he's just like on
facetime he's like i love you i love you
so much honey then he gets off and he's
like oh yeah
every guys do that thing where you
pretend like you're not having fun yeah
it sucks out here we're getting our ass
kicked the crabs you can miss the family
and still have fun but you do have to
pretend a little bit you gotta play it
down yeah yes sir i wish you were here
honey
boys shucking oysters this is terrible
honey
a line off of a hooker's tit yeah you
know i got the sniffles
i need your tlc honey it really it is
weird you do have to pretend i mean i do
miss my girlfriend when i'm on the road
but you do have to like up it a little
bit you do something where you're like
yeah well it sucks is we made this
decision to pursue a dream and it's
coming true
but then you have to dial it back for
the the wife or the girlfriend so it's a
weird because she knows you like comedy
yeah so it's kind of a tough sell
right like oh you're going on the road
you're going to do tell some jokes
you're like i know but i also had to
give 10 years up in my life to
eat dollar pizza and uh you know drink
pat's through the ribbon and bomb
and work working six day jobs i used i
used to [ __ ] eat so badly on the road
oh yeah i used to eat that i had to club
meal for like 10 years
same i'm like [ __ ] man i really got used
to uh pulled pork sandwiches yeah and uh
and they weren't even good pulled pork
sandwiches it was like [ __ ] they were
literally dog food that they do barbecue
sauce on they were like this is your
dinner exactly and i would i was so
broke i would you know you got a club
meal at seven so i would wouldn't eat
all day
i would you were you would go excessive
though i remember you would do like the
granny smith hotel apples
i did those but mark would do this for
like meals i was like i need to get a
meal i need like eggs or something the
hotel in cala in san francisco by the
punch line used to give you free nuts
and that was a game changer it's funny
when hotels have like weird they'd have
like a like a
happy hour and yeah they just have like
fried food it's kind of cool i know i
love that just five o'clock it's
champagne and and like uh sliders or
something i used to get so rock hard for
a free hotel breakfast and now i'm like
i'm [ __ ] sleeping in is worth so much
to me now it's true it's true but
sometimes you get a waft of that waffle
in the air you like a good uh hotel
lobby i do i do you put the butter the
syrup oh man
it's like home
yeah i'm not a big waffle guy
i mean they i just don't want to start
my day with maple syrup and butter it's
true it's uh it's a horrible time i
don't wanna i'll do it at like 2 a.m
which is probably equally bad for you if
not worse probably probably worse i'm
like i like i don't like to start my day
with butter and syrup i like to do it uh
right before my head hits the pillow
that's hard
it's true yeah no but egg something like
ritualistic about having like my eggs in
my coffee i like eggs every day yeah i
like eggs too i like making overnight
oats too but that's a lot of work
yeah i go instant in the morning you go
instant instant out every day did it
today
you love you're a man of routine oh yeah
oh yeah i try to be somewhat routine i
feel like and if you fall out of it you
feel guilty and it keeps you back in it
yeah you know seinfeld used to have that
thing where he said he wrote every day
and he would x out the day on the
calendar and if he missed an x
he felt terrible and that smart would
make you
not skip
i love it man well i think that's great
uh
eggs for breakfast i have to do every
every day or something about it why is
that with with with food and time like
if you ate a tuna sandwich at eight a.m
we'd all go what the [ __ ] is wrong with
this psycho i mean i'll
i'll do i don't mind starting my day
with like tuna but it's gotta be like
two people i don't know something about
waking up in tuna that's what i'm saying
but then it at 10 pm tuna is fine isn't
that weird something about the sun or
the heat or in japan fish is a common
breakfast yes yeah but then we have
limes
we have locks though but locks are
accepted it's weird how some stuff is in
and out
yeah that is weird yeah this is okay
as i think hey man if you're giving me
the the death sentence in the morning
i'm having locks oh man i'm having a
bagel right locks with avocado
can't beat it capers
papers are the supporting players
they're the joe pesci they never get the
respect but they're carrying that bagel
a little bit good point and they're
little they're little yeah tiny and
round
funny house
what's that hard to pull off a caper
i like capers and pasta dude i'll throw
some capers oh i'm making pasta i throw
some capers in that [ __ ] cream pasta no
i'll do like a like a
kind of like a pudding esca type uh
pasta i like i like making pasta i don't
know what it what the hell's a puna
pooka nesca it's like olives and red
sauce and it's good it's just the uh
used to making the [ __ ] houses that's
the name yeah which is horror yeah is
that right i didn't know that everything
just put everything in the in the pot
pore sauce
whoa
i like that
horse sauce i try not to say that when i
hand it to my girlfriend i said
or sauce now it's called fireball
[Laughter]
trash is that still relevant i don't
even know if that joke plays yeah i
think people still okay okay that was
that had a moment that was the biggest
liquor for like two days
who [ __ ] it's all branding because
it's terrible it's terrible it's sugar
it's cinnamon with whiskey yes it's like
big red
that's what it is which is what her name
was too i'll tell you
clifford
clifford
why is this movie uh there's something
about a giant red dog that's off-putting
you just think of bloody
yeah you look like michael vick's dog it
looks too real
it looks too real yeah i don't know and
then you just picture them having to die
the dog behind the scenes you know the
whole thing is it's all cgi isn't it oh
that makes sense i assume it's died go
to the trailer
no we can't we can't play videos
remember we lost all our money you know
it's weird though
the scene do you see the scene where
they show his [ __ ] that was crazy what
no i'm kidding
i was like well wait pull that up that's
worth the monetizing
can we just get a photo of him yeah
that's cgi dude are you kidding me the
red i mean i know the size is
it's just all fake it's not oh okay
damn i i like the idea of them dying him
oh that looks really good oh is that a
real dog i don't know that is
hey is that jack whitehall uh yeah that
guy's in a lot of movies now yeah he's a
hunk he's a he's a funny guy that's one
of his fans he was good oh he kills he's
huge in england yeah
clifford what uh
what
what is that matt told me not to play
clips too long yeah yeah yeah smart
smart we got the gist yeah we got it but
yeah man san fran by the way they hate
when you say san francisco i don't say
it video said he got called out i've
learned my lesson i've been there enough
times sf call them out
a local oh yeah someone just said
walking by don't say that yeah we ran
into people on the street a couple times
and he said it's like great to be back
in san fran what first of all you've
been saying that what are you on stage
you don't have to say that right hanging
out but it's always great to be it's a
good yeah i love being in san fran they
were like it's sf and i was like i knew
that i'm not doing it yeah they don't
like it yeah people get weird it's uh
there's a couple other ones spokane they
hate they don't call cans yeah spokane
yeah they don't care about the homeless
there but pronunciation they're very
particular yeah right a lot of heroin
over there it's funny doing crowd work
there because you're like where do you
work facebook how about you google
you're just going through like all these
tech companies you get someone who
doesn't work in tech you're like thank
god i know
is that city going to come back because
it's one of those cities i don't want to
lose well i mean
i don't know if it'll come back but i
mean it's it's still going to be great
it's going to be a different it's going
to be a little a lot of cities have i
mean dallas is tech now phoenix is tech
like a lot of places have tech now right
yeah it just sucks when the city city is
just full of homeless then outside of
the city is like
what is that san jose area it's like
beautiful with the all the google and
everything but then the city gets left
behind well yeah it's horrible it's like
it's it's weird to see that much of a
discrepancy i mean it's like literally
like dawn of the dead and then star trek
you see a guy like hovering through
garbage and another guy float behind a
hovercraft you're like what the [ __ ]
exactly exactly this is not good yeah
that group's going bigger this one's
getting smaller and and they just whizz
by on the hoverboard and the guy's
taking a [ __ ] on the sidewalk yeah so
yeah big there's no middle no middle i
guess we're the middle we're in the
middle we fly in we do a set and we fly
out well feeder's the middle
but yeah i i gotta tell i was in houston
that is a great comedy town it is great
i got to get there soon i'm trying to
try to book a date there oh man good
crowds just fun that's skankfest i mean
say what you will about those guys they
have the best fans i wish i could have
made it for a night the funnest crowds i
mean me and liz did a live tuesdays we
did a stand-up show ari got dosed
somebody toast ahri to get him back yeah
it was just the ghost him kim congdon
no she asked slipped acid in his drink
jesus christ this is not good it was
true wrongs this isn't hammurabi's code
here what the hell are we doing well you
don't do someone to dose him he
shouldn't have done that but you don't
doze him back in her defense and you
might appreciate this he was wearing the
kobe jersey when she did it so wow i
mean there was all kinds of chaos out
there jesus christ it was just a [ __ ]
[ __ ] it felt like old comedy like we're
just getting wild and reckless and drunk
and drugs and lewis pulls up on a
clydesdale like what's going on i was
with ari right after he did the kobe
thing i remember like on the street and
there were people walking by like we
know what you did and i remember he was
already like let's uh let's go walk to
the cellar and i was like i'm gonna take
a cab i think
i just picture a drive-by going by yeah
yeah that's tough
he was not well liked after that
yeah even comics i saw were like
no thanks
well i'm not gonna like not hang out
with him but i was like can we [ __ ]
do it in like a private brand venue yeah
yeah
that was a dark days for him he lost a
special did over that he had a spell i
don't know if i'm supposed to say it
kobe lost more that's true that's true
well you know kobe's a real helicopter
parent but uh all right but i will say i
had to get that out uh ari had a show at
the skirball center was shooting on a
netflix or something and they they
called it off it was like too many
people were calling in going we're gonna
riot the theater or protest the theater
whatever it was so they just
all right we can't get you here by car
we're gonna have to take a helicopter
he's like [ __ ]
baby
yeah three points
um
yeah that was all net but uh yeah so
there are consequences out there kids
yeah that's a very relatable problem a
lot of kids out there are losing netflix
specials because of their shitty jokes
what the hell
[Laughter]
was awesome oh it looked awesome the
pictures looked awesome and uh i saw bob
sagan was there it looked fun they had
fun
guys gilbert yeah
watching doug stanhope karaoke with
shane gill i mean the whole thing was
just like surrealism
is a must guest on this yes i love doug
i i think of his joke all the time
on one of his jokes on one of his albums
where he said uh
when i do comedy it's like i'm bringing
you into war you're not all gonna be
here at the end
that's one of the most comedy lines ever
it's like oh that sums it up man that's
perfect and it's it's great because he
had to have enough walkouts to write a
joke about it you know what i mean
i love [ __ ] great i think he's uh
he's a he's a classic classic sweet guy
and and some of some of the albums you
got to check out uh no refunds i think
it's like his masterpiece oh someone
take the edge off i remember listening
to as a kid being like wow this is
pretty hit henry phillips doing the
guitar yeah great i mean yeah stan
hope's a he's a classic man his opener
junior stopga also underrated he's so
dark that i don't know if he'll ever
blow up but he had this one joke and if
this is too dark
feel free to don't put us on the spot
like this all right
his joke his jokes yeah i don't know i
think it's on an album but he says uh
you know the holocaust actually had a
lot of [ __ ] people in it nobody
talks about that and they have the first
sentence is like the two yeah
he goes
uh sorry that's the setup holocaust had
a lot of [ __ ] people in it uh but
they can't post the photos because
they're all smiling oh jesus that's
funny
that's a good joke i mean that's dark as
hell but that is smart that's a smart
take
it's a clever [ __ ] holocaust joke
all right we'll we'll wind it back i i
wanna i think i'm gonna call my next
special i have a lot of holocaust jokes
in my next special i have like 9 11
jokes i have pedophilia jokes i have
abortion jokes i think i'm going to call
it 9 11 abortion pedophilia because
because no one will complain
you know what i mean like no one's going
to be like i expected better oh yeah
that's like i think that's the move i
like that maybe that's the move i don't
know yeah or you can call it don't
forget
something never forget this album
i like that though you put it all out
there like this is the movie what uh man
that's a dark joke that's dark joke
are you allowed to p you definitely
can't say that word on
like nbc or something can you say i mean
can you say it on like comedy central
like cable running with that word on
your special i was told not to say it on
netflix because um
one other guy said it but his was
mine was more like come on you [ __ ]
and so they were like ah it's pointless
to just use it as an insult and i was
like that's fair but his was like in the
joke like it was part of the joke
so i i
seceded or whatever the word is
conceded thank you
i conceded i was like i get that so i
changed it to something else
huh yeah i've had stuff like that where
it's just it's like you're like oh i
could find a better word so it's no
point like like use the offensive word
when you have to and if you can avoid it
right like save it when you really need
it and then that time it'll hit even
harder because it's more unexpected
which is fair yeah it's fair and it
tends to make you write a better
line for sure because i was relying on
the the shock and awe of the word
[ __ ] but with it with a new line i
had to actually make it have shocked
change it to the n word yeah there you
go
uh
[Music]
oh
all right these are from culture club
sorry
culture
culture espresso hey you got a new
boombox is this are they all the same
kind matter what are we looking at here
yeah chocolate chips
chocolate chip is not my favorite cookie
whoa
i'm a big oatmeal raisin guy what you
are too is that weird yes why over cheat
chocolate chip that's a great cookie
that's a fatty too look at the size of
that thing you wanna you wanna pull
there sally yeah get in there buddy
there's only two so take some mine
thank you there you go this is a
delightful cookie oh man it's one of
these cookies where it's it's baked in
the chocolate
oh man this is this is a good radio all
of a sudden check it out right
hold on this is incredible
oh you dipped the cookie oh yeah
maybe i should
yeah that's an incredible cookie it's
weird dunkin donuts is named after
dunking your donuts in the coffee but i
don't see anybody dunking their donut
anymore people dunk oh really i i used
to go to knicks games and
uh you know in the 90s if the knicks won
the tip off everyone gets a free donut
what dunkin donuts it's like it's a good
promotion because everyone's like oh
duncan i'll go to dunkin
but but ewing won a lot of tip-offs ah
you see him right there he won a lot of
those tip-offs after the game like dad
we have to go to duncan please it works
it worked yeah
we just had that was the most seinfeld
and george moment of all time i don't
see a lot of people dunk anymore they
don't
[Laughter]
this is an incredible cookie quick
cookie joe dimaggio comes that's right
joe dimaggio yeah you'd think they would
dunk a donut when the guy dunked yeah
the the yankee clipper baby
was right there there's 500 dunks a game
though
no not that much i think bobby jewel and
tampa had a joe dimaggio jersey in his
house whoa yeah like like framed whoa
look at this it's drenched in marilyn
monroe's [ __ ] juice right here
[Laughter]
yeah no he the dimaggio man that guy
lived the life
you know even though they were divorced
in maryland he said flowers to her grave
wow every week until he died every week
i mean he also hit her so he's not like
the greatest guy but
yeah you know you even out
i'm sure of course like i mean you could
have done some of this stuff when i was
alive i'm sure
uh i watched the arthur miller
documentary i hear it's incredible it's
really great some great writing tips
yeah i remember i memorized one because
i wanted to say it on here
he said you're you're your best writer
when you're on the edge of embarrassment
um you know when you're like i can't say
this is too silly that's when you're at
your best and then you dial it back a
little you don't all you don't go over
the edge and embarrass yourself but you
go right to the edge and stop there
someone walks in while you're
masturbating you're like good yeah this
guy's prolific
what does that mean
what do you think that means exactly i
think that means you got to get
vulnerable and get close to like letting
out everything
but don't let it all don't don't spill
your guts and be annoying but stop it
right at the edge and that's when you're
at your best you're like edging but yes
but for your soul creative edging yeah
yeah but he was like a sexy jewish guy
brilliant i mean death of a salesman
i saw brian dennehy in death of a
salesman on broadway wow as a kid my
parents took us and we he was incredible
brian dennehy was a [ __ ] great actor
yeah beast of a man beast of a man that
was a tommy boy's dad right yeah yeah
yeah oh that's a that's such an
unexpected scene and tommy boy when you
just die you're like wait what
we're opening this comedy with your dad
collapsing i know i rewatched that the
other night drunk and it's still great
it's fun to love a good re-watch drunk
yeah i will say it's fun watching movies
from the 90s comedies because there's a
little air in them like now i feel like
it's just bam bam joke joke joke there
was a little bit more uh fluff in the
middle i showed taylor nutty professor
from the 90s recently and i will say
this eddie murphy deserved an oscar
nomination oh yeah that's an incredible
about it dude he plays like 10 people
and it's like credit for playing like a
fat guy not just going for cheap jokes
like there's some cheap 90s jokes in
there but like that character's got
heart you know oh yeah oh yeah and then
buddy love is [ __ ] hilarious right
and then he plays basically plays
richard simmons in it yeah that's right
and then he plays the whole family those
dinner scenes are incredible he's the
mom he's the dad the grandma he's the
grandma yeah come on cletus that whole
thing the dad's name is cletus yes you
know he just wanted to say cletus this
is a good example though of people who
go you know people go you could never
make that movie now and everybody goes
shut up you could never make this movie
now the whole movie is about fat people
yeah it's about being fat no that's bad
but it's got heart and the message at
the end is like loving who you are
that's true it's actually got so maybe
you could make it
maybe maybe
i don't know i think they'd be like you
don't need to lose weight just love who
you are though but that's what they did
in the 90s
but didn't he get hot
yeah but then at the end it's like he he
was like it's about loving who you are
oh okay so maybe it's yeah it's proof
that you can't make it because amy got
roasted online for i feel pretty oh
that's true that's true
why do you
yeah
i don't know but eddie murphy they threw
on a fat suit yeah i mean they tried to
make this a version of this later with
uh shallow hal that's right that's right
and that was a pretty bad movie yeah i
love it just wasn't it it just felt like
mean it was also weird that jack black
was like this womanizer
jack black and jason alexander the two
uh ladies men right right
and then it's also weird because you get
like gwyneth paltrow playing like
fat and it was all just weird and then
her interviews were terrible she was
like it was horrible
that's not what you do and then yeah no
one wants to hear a skinny white woman
be like it was terrible right i was so
fat
the fairly brothers had a run huh i mean
they were on fire for a while i heard
that they didn't write dumb and dumber
really whoever john hughes wrote it
dumb and dumber's incred i've rewatched
that on a flight
because you know you're just stressing
you're like man this is a great it's so
good that might be like my ultimate
comfort watch yeah
it's it's up there as one of the best
comedies i'd say because it's just
there's no importance to it it's just
funny
and it's just non i mean they're so good
together you can't
it goes to show you when you try to
recreate a comedy 20 years later like
look they did it with that they did it
with like coming to america even longer
the magic's gone dude i know
i know it's just it's gone yeah you're
different people now it's sad how good
and this is gonna this maybe it isn't
sad maybe i should
reflect on the fact that we had it was
like eddie murphy and jim carrey in the
90s where he's in sandler dude and
sandler i mean it was just comedy
coming it was oozing out of him it was
unbelievable comedy got chris farley
movies
look at that run at the bottom there
dumb and dumber kingpin something about
mary me myself and irene myself and
irene's underrated i agree that's got
hard too renee zellweger is great in it
too yeah she's she's knows how to play
straight for jim carrey
i think stuck on you is underrated
what's that it's greg kinnear and matt
damon or uh i guess conjoined twins i
was gonna say siamese but i guess you
also can't say anymore uh they're
conjoined twins and it's like basically
they're growing up and one falls in love
with someone and it's like and it's like
how they're trying to there's great
scenes where like they're trying to have
sex and the other one just like read a
book and he's just having sex because
they're conjoined right because greg
kneer's the kind of a ladies man and
matt damon's the shy guy
really meryl streep is a cameo it's
pretty funny i think it got bad reviews
but i saw it i was like i think it's
really good really all right i think i
saw the box and was like this is going
to be dumb it was dumb but it was still
fun all right steph's brother is also
funny i mean who doesn't who doesn't
think step brothers is funny yeah i just
don't feel like it gets brought up
enough step brothers i i don't hear it
no is it people talking about that okay
oh my god yeah i feel like the one that
doesn't get brought up for will ferrell
and it is hilarious is the other guys
other guy with mark wahlberg that's a
great movie i never saw that one oh it's
[ __ ] dude all right i feel like that
came out and nice guys came out and i
was like
they're both too much okay and they're
both very different okay all right both
greg
oh dude i rewatched uh the last boy
scout i hadn't seen that since i was
like very young man it is not a good
movie you like it i remember when i was
a kid i mean it's it is you watch you
watch some of those like 80s and early
90s action movies you're like this is
insane i mean we watched lethal weapon
two and just the the first shot of
lethal weapon is a woman with giant fake
tits open shirt naked and she just jumps
off a building
this is all it took to open like imagine
screenwriting you're like her tits are
huge
and she jumped through a car and you're
like yeah yeah
last boy scout has so many scenes here
like this is it's bruce willis and damon
wayans and it's like uh
is this her
yeah what do you know this is this isn't
it
is the opening scene this isn't it
well if it's on youtube yeah
yeah you can't we can't do but matt we
can't get away with this can we are we
gonna get pulled from youtube
well they they won't put the boobs on
there
they could it's no they don't know no
nudity oh that's not even worth saying
yep all right and then we're just
watching a woman jump
well whatever gets you hard
you know uh last boy scout it opens with
like uh
bruce willis has some it's some great
lies but then sometimes you're like
jesus christ like his friend immediately
his friend [ __ ] him over uh and uh
[ __ ] his wife and and he like walks in
on it and he's just like when do we stop
being friends he's like when you started
[ __ ] my wife
and then right after that he's like head
of body and he punches him in the body
and then the friend walks into a car and
it just explodes what it's so much you
could tell they're just like just
[ __ ] add an explosion
[Laughter]
it reminds me that simpsons episode
where homer's trying to cook and he puts
some [ __ ] in the oven to catch on fire
he tries something else he puts it into
the microwave and cuts on fire then he
pours cereal into a bowl and he catches
them i love that [ __ ] oh so good dude uh
erica leniak had a great topless moment
in under siege which one was that that
was the steven seagal on the boat he was
on like an aircraft isn't that like
supposed to be his only good one it is
it's pretty good yeah that guy is a
real weird guy yeah
it's so funny that like some of those
action scenes or you see clips and
you're like is he just like
you see like jackie chan he's doing like
backflips and like creative stunts
steven seagal is just doing like [ __ ]
with his hands i know and you're just
like i get that maybe this would work in
real life but it's not very cinematic
yes yes and he does [ __ ] where you're
like
did you know that was funny or were you
is that you sincere he's so can we are
we able to play this yeah
well i don't know you tell us there
people i mean whatever who cares if we
don't mind hey there she is
uh she was a baywatch fame
erika leniak also at charles in charge
wait a minute oh
see they can't show it on youtube is
that youtube yeah wow so i'm taking it
all back
all those tips could be guns
i think they don't open up the shirt by
the way
that's [ __ ] yeah
i don't think i ever saw steven seagal
movies i think well i saw exit wounds
terrible movie nice no tupac dmx dude oh
he's in the movie
i believe is he i think he invented his
own martial arts style
steven seagal
i thought it was like aikido or
something it's something like that oh
maybe maybe he made one popular at least
hmm
but yeah he's got the ponytail some of
those old movies dude they're just
they're just [ __ ] turds oh yeah but
we watched them those 90s movies you
really didn't have to because i looked
up i'm like this last boy scout this
could have done well in the box office
it was like 114 million in the early 90s
so that's good that's good that's good
now i mean you saw bruce willis on a
movie box you went and saw it veder told
me he saw it in the theater with his dad
and i was like how old were you and he's
like probably seven the movie literally
opens with a football player with a gun
shooting people on the field and then
taking the gun and shooting himself in
the head
you're taking your child yeah there he
is aikido did he come up with this or is
this oh okay
i mean i don't think so i think he's
been around
he was a cop in louisiana for a while i
mean stephen segal has really run the
gamut but it's so unexciting yeah
like the other guy's doing all the
exciting things just throwing people
around
this is hilarious that is pretty cool
though this is what my dad used to do to
me
i just booty bumped him
this can't be real yeah
turns getting his ass kicked
what the hell man this is good coffee by
the way that cookie not too shabby
either no is this good coffee because
you know your coffee so i want to know
because i know my coffee i think i just
drink a lot of it
i think it's good coffee is there a term
for a coffee addict you got alcoholic
you got chocoholic you got
meth head
what's the coffee one meth head caffeine
meth tooth yeah that's true it's really
weird we were noticing right cocaine the
teeth are in the head
yeah coffeaholic oh
that sounds like a guy with coven
[Laughter]
um
any peeves this week oh i got too many
because i haven't seen you in so long
but i'll save some save some but give me
a couple i'll give you a couple here how
about this
i went to a bar
in portland after my shows like a dive
bar
i love a good dive bar
and i do the thing where i go give me a
high life and a tequila soda or whatever
and they go all right that'll be uh
868. what does this change now i'm now
i'm kidding really 868 it was like 8.75
i think it was 8.50 or something but
still i'm like now i'm dealing with
change at a bar i hate the change at a
bar dollar bills only round up a round
down exactly yeah so now you're giving
someone like a tip of 250. yes exactly
very weird charge me nine and i'll be
having charge me the extra 50 cents i'd
rather that than being like i'm scooping
up change or i just give them the change
and you look like a like a
deadbeat either way was it a cash-only
bar too it was that's insane it's insane
also bringing cash to a bar is crazy
that feels like a place to get robbed
now that's where people probably jump
you because you're bringing cash out
these days cash is rare and some people
don't even take cash anymore have you
seen this i i do just a tip
just like leo bug i'll get change a tip
like leave something in the hotel room
something like that but like i don't
i don't uh i don't walk around with cash
usually oh i do do you oh yeah let's see
how much cash i have on me this could be
fun i got some do the whole thing oh you
know what i do have cash on me on the
table please yeah i got cash
how much do you have on you should we
count yep wow you got a lot
hell
yeah count it
oh man
see i got a lot of fives and and and
tens because of tips and stuff yeah yeah
yeah but let's see
yeah i got about like 150 or so here i
don't have a ton of cash on me
look at you jesus man what the hell what
are you guys doing
what is this the sopranos what the hell
are you doing here
oh man look at that
mark what are you no this is not smart
what the hell are you doing oh my god
why did you eat this kind of casual
store i mean this is over a thousand
dollars in cash here that's i mean in
hundreds alone you don't want this out
there people are gonna rob you well this
is a fluke this is a fluke
get the cookie um
so i did a show i did rogan and then he
goes you guys want to do a set on my
show at the whatever room we go sure and
now we're like half in the bag he feeds
you whiskey all night so now me and
shane and ari go to his show and then i
didn't realize this we do his show he
takes us all out for burgers after and
he goes oh i gotta pay you he gives us a
thousand dollars each in cash oh wow he
pays you a thousand dollars we did 12
minutes classy guy classy guy i mean
when you got that much dough you know
you can really throw it around
really cool that's mostly where this is
from then the rest is from just random
[ __ ] the camera we want rewind is who
brought up the idea of how much cash we
have in our pockets because it was you
yeah why he knew how much money
yeah well i knew it'd be a good visual
leave that for the intern man
like 75
yeah consider money right now oh that's
good but no i gotta die i thought i
would have none on me
i just happen to throw on show pants
so um
do you ever get a guy handing you money
after a show like that was a great set
here you go here you go
i don't really do the meet and greets
anymore i'm too tired i get it i get it
it's it's exhausting i'll do it with
three shoes yeah
um
yeah
i'll do it again but man some of those
drunks they just ruin it for for
everybody they really do
i i had one guy he got thrown out of the
4pm show in san francisco
he was that drunk
that's crazy he was uh
he was just like yelling stuff out he's
like you like cocaine i was like well i
can tell you do yeah he goes i'm on a
lot of cocaine i was like all right i
was like i hope you're all right man and
he was like freaking out a little bit
that's bad
i'm like it's a [ __ ] matinee dude
i know you coked out of the matinee
yeah right
it's just wild like i'll get i'll check
my uh what do you call those like the
insta stories where they tag you and
it'll be like
we're out the bar and it's like eight
guys doing shots like going to the
norman show and i'm like the next one of
them just beating the [ __ ] out of a
homeless guy like
jesus
animals and you're like look i
appreciate you coming i'm glad you guys
are excited but like this is still a
show you know it's still a sit down in a
chair and be civil and civilized but
some people just get blacked out
yeah don't pre-game for a comedy show
enjoy the show you could be gamer just
don't
just know your limits yes no you're
living like we like boozing we like
drunks but just
we like drunks we keep it together i get
booze sometimes when i have a water
bottle on stage i'm trying to stay
hydrated here so i can put on a good
show and people are like do a shot and
i'm like i got two more of these tonight
dude yeah i gotta have to get to the
venue at 3 30 in the afternoon
that's the irony do a shot you're like
the show will be worse your show will
suck i try to plan the the coffee into
booze thing very well especially on
those three show nights because you're
like booze or muscle relax so what are
we doing tonight and i want and usually
it's booze you know i want the sleepy
you just got to accept you're not
getting sleep some of these nights and
then the next day you feel [ __ ]
incredible i i got like seven hours last
night i feel like a million bucks no
better feeling no better feeling it's
the ultimate
supercharger but
yeah some nights so i'm just like all
right are you playing like
sorry the cookie
the cookie you had two bites mark you
gave him half your cookie you don't
blame me
[Laughter]
he burped she's like the money it was
the money then
i thought one great thing about the mask
because i've been farting on these
planes and nobody notices no one can it
is nice on the planes they can't smell
you can you can fart on planes oh yeah
yeah you can't no no i don't oh yeah no
it's like because of the mass though you
don't really feel as much guilt no guilt
nobody knows i've gotten a few of these
before like
but now with the mask i never see that
sometimes they do it right when they're
serving food
i did a first class you did first class
cross country i mean i i use upgrades on
that [ __ ] dude no it's worth it you need
i mean it's like you just want to not
feel like i mean especially on a 7 a.m
flight problem is everyone watching on
the 7 a.m because they want to sleep yep
yeah but i did portland and then la and
i'm going to vancouver this weekend so
i'm on my third week of west coast
thanks for not staying out there i i get
how it makes sense no no i mean i knew
we had to get back plus the ladies
getting annoyed with all the travel but
thank god thanksgiving's coming up yeah
a little uh quality time yeah
thanksgiving's a good time yeah one of
the best holidays
but uh my point is i got first class on
one of them and it was united polaris
why you gotta stick with one airline
what are you doing
i don't know if this is one of mark's
cons like the money but you stick with
one airline you get upgraded all the
time because you have status you know
that way i know and i did it with i ran
with delta for years but then uh delta
is good delta's great that's my favorite
airline but
that is united
i had to take it there's footage of me
[ __ ] on delta
in one of my specials i have like a long
delta but it's like they've really
become my favorite they [ __ ] me once
and now i'm like but always forgiving
they all [ __ ] at some point yeah
they're all [ __ ] but it's the best
airline by far
i like that lounge oh the united lounge
sucks does it oh my god it sucks it was
jam-packed and i was sitting at a table
and this indian couple was like can we
sit with you let's do it i was like yeah
please please i sat down we started
chatting we had a great time he's like
no one wants to work this this lounge is
trash you know it was just great and we
he's like i'm a delta guy and this
lounge sucks they have like cup of
noodles and uh ritz cracker it's
horrible and
how do you feel about ritz crackers i'm
not a cracker guy really not even like i
think wheat fins are pretty good i'm in
the minority here you like crackers yeah
okay to me it's just you're eating it's
like cardboard with salt that's the
whitest [ __ ] ever
i'm a big fan of all crackers yeah i
love crackers i uh
what's your favorite i i love a ritz i
like a wheat bin how about a triscuit
that's not a cracker oh really we got a
debate here how about one of those like
fancy like cars crack pepper type
crackers as long as there's cheese
oh cheese on it yeah i could spread some
cheese see now it's a vehicle because
you just want the cheese yeah that's why
i don't like it
same with bread i'm off bread because i
want the meat i want the mayo i want the
lettuce the tomato i don't need the
bread
you don't want a sandwich to me that's
like i think we just grew up in new york
so it's like you need deli sandwiches
were like a part of my diet for so long
i can't just shake them like i still go
to my corner store just to get an egg
sandwich like every day i mean look at
sandwiches can't be but we're getting
one later and that's why i got the wrap
because i want the egg sandwich
like i grew up with po boys which is
like 88 bread and then shrimp or beef or
whatever so you were over breaded i was
over breaded yeah yeah so now i'm off
bread i'm going against the grain
all right that's a tweet
but yeah who needs it i feel like i'm
getting duped
like do you know you get these pieces of
slices you don't like good bread i do
but it's like a good
baguette not really i don't want too
much i don't like when it's like crazy
oh man but like a good panini or
something i'm [ __ ] i love making a
panini but you ever get that [ __ ] you
ever get a thick crust piece of pizza
and you're like this is bread and then
this is the topping yeah but chicago
does it right all right but i'm i'm a
thin crust guy for sure oh yeah like new
york's consistency with pizza like
everyone talks like what's your spot in
new york i'm like that's the beauty of
new york you don't even need a spot good
point because every corner spot is solid
that's a good story so people like where
are you going like that's how good it is
we don't celebrate it yeah we just know
i like that
you know joe's is great but the next one
down is like right here yeah
joe's also late night slip sometimes
like they'll hand you like a burnt slice
and you're just like dude
and they're like all right i'm like you
tried the [ __ ] con me yeah you tried
to con me with a burnt slice and you
thought cause it was 2 a.m you're gonna
get away with it because the dream you
didn't count on is i'm sober because i
just did a set yeah the drunks won't
notice but you got it yeah they think
because they got a picture of leonardo
dicaprio on the wall they can get away
with her young leo too so it's legit hot
leo
he's got a new uh young young lady he
dates really young 22 it's very young
it's something's missing when you go
that young oh yeah you go hey you ever
seen that alf who's elf you're like all
right
that's my barometer that's my test
you ladies know elf yeah let's [ __ ]
[Laughter]
are you on the one with uh with ted
mcginley or the guy before
steve
yes
is that her man he's had a
resume of real betty's huh
holy hell
jeez louise i heard he's uh packing a
piece too you know he probably gets rid
of them really easily like he bangs him
and he's like we need to talk about
climate change i'm like all right i'm
out of here
yeah he does the whole thing where he
saves the tigers that's his move
yeah so even his philanthropy is cool
you know it's not just like hey we got
to recycle it's like hey we got to help
these times we need to stop the next
season from happening you know that was
a lion but cougar
he likes he likes um nice
he likes um
it's weird like some people see people
be like you know save the elephants yeah
and it is cruel when you see like these
elephants that are like gigantic and
they're just in uh this cage and then
you're like well then you think about
how we live our apartments aren't that
big either yeah goodbye uh they're
getting free food
i mean they are prisoners but yeah yeah
but chris rock had that great but i love
a bit where he says uh save the trees
save the trees [ __ ] i see trees
every day
i was at the the thanksgiving day parade
i saw two real indians and the rest were
[ __ ] puerto ricans he's like when's
the last time he saw an indian family
eating a red lobster
i love that joke damn oh wow look how
young
man he was hunky huh
well actually he's more twinky but he's
cute he's just so young he looks like a
hot chick
yeah would you
i think as a in the gilbert grape days i
would have you give him a little
basketball diary's action yeah
now what is it with men their face gets
wider
val kilmer has it alec baldwin
is cancer well and alex baldwin is very
old well i'm just saying but the face
goes out for some reason i hope that
doesn't happen to us maybe it's from
killing a man or a woman i'm sorry
yeah rittenhouse's got a huge face but
there's a face
but yeah just saying it's something
about dudes their face gets bigger and i
thought it was cause of booze
for women too i think your face just
gets you get a little fatter it's just
part of getting older
yeah but some people get it and some
people don't i don't know yeah like brad
pitt's still got a nice face i swear
yeah
does he he's also definitely had work
done oh
there's no way brad pitt hasn't had work
done right i bet he has
you get that you're that bit you're
known for it you gotta you gotta
maintain it
make a big face robert redford was like
the brad pitt of his day oh yeah there's
work done you can see the uh the eyes
are a little squintier yeah
still looks great don't get me wrong but
like he's actually he's working on new
film on memoirs of a geisha right now
uh
brad pitt i mean look at robert redford
he did not get any work done and he
looks like uh the crypt keeper
he's 87. i know he looks
you know he uh
yeah redford was cool man oh he was like
the brad pitt of his day and look at
that though newman was like the the
clooney yeah clooney's on marin today by
the way i listened already is it good
it's really good he's such a normal guy
it's great i [ __ ] love clooney love
you want to hate him but let's see
there's a redford in the middle that red
shirt yikes that'll wake the dead but
once he made like good night and good
luck i was like nah he's legit he's a
legit like film guy well what's cool
about uh clooney is he did all those
like fluffy [ __ ] like
facts of god what is it just the facts
what was that
facts of life all that you are yeah one
fine day yes all just to direct he did
all that it's like us like we do all
these open mics and all this [ __ ] just
so we can headline one day yeah
real deal real deal and handsome would
you
i might go down on him would you if you
were a woman is he is he your type i
would [ __ ] him in the ass there you go
i'll give you that really i would i
wouldn't let him [ __ ] me but i would
[ __ ] him
i'd give them all oceans 11 inches
all right
really scraping the barrel today
i need some booze yeah but we need to
burn after reading this conversation
here
oh brother where are those jokes
but yeah clooney's cool yeah and he gave
his friends each a million when he sold
his 14 14 friends
million each he sucked to be that 15th
friend oh
yeah that would be a bummer
like i thought you're like you're like i
thought that was kind of i thought we
were closing because you always think
you're closer with someone at that level
right or how about the guy was like
tequila company you really want to do
that then later he's like oh i was going
to give you a million but you told me
not to do it
so [ __ ] you
yeah
damn
yeah it sucks
oh yeah
yeah yeah all right let's do it right
now uh
yeah we might be drunk to you as brought
by uh we might be drunk is brought to
you by sheath underwear i love sheath
man love it not only supportive keeps
your balls off your leg it's got two
patches one for your dick one for your
balls but sheath isn't just for men it's
for the lady gays out there she's now
they they wrote this well uh now has
sports bras bikini briefs and boy shorts
the idea for sheath came from its
founder u.s army soldier robert padden
during his second tour in iraq this
guy's a veteran he's a us hero support
this guy support this awesome
veteran-owned company whose founder is a
big comedy fan oh tell
you got that right go to sheath
underwear dot com and order with promo
code drunk to get 20 off your first
order and sheets underwear is 100 money
back guarantee that's sheath
underwear.com promo code drunk get
sheathed underwear and let them support
your balls
robert the guy who runs this thing
robert patton was at skankfest i mean
this guy is the real deal he's all in
and also if you leave us a nice review
uh on the podcast app or itunes or
whatever you use you're eligible to win
a a package of sheets isn't that right i
forgot about it so that's yeah there we
go good call and this is good stuff
folks
it's not robert pattinson
it's just it's just the new batman's
underwear company
another hunk by the way and a good actor
time out or was it called another guy
who did twilight but it's like you could
tell he actually like wants to do good
[ __ ] exactly you gotta get in the door
folks some ladies do it with porn and
tits and
yeah
we all remember laura lenny's uh porn
face
[Laughter]
she's great
great actress she was at gotham one
night what yeah she was in the crowd i
was like i was like like i want to meet
laura lenny but she was yeah was she she
ozarks ozarks yeah yeah yeah she's good
good actress was she
no who might think of who's in the c
word
the c word wasn't that an s show
she's kind of hot in a weird way
i don't know if that's insulting yeah i
don't think it's a compliment i don't
think i mean you can say it i don't
think a woman will be like hey you're
attractive in a very strange off-putting
way i don't know what it is well it's a
little she's off off the beaten path a
little bit uh a unique look i think
that's how you say it there you go who's
in the c word oh maybe it wasn't her the
l word maybe the l word is that
something i don't know
the l word that's your knowing matt all
right well just don't go to the n word
that's a whole different show is it one
of these women no no she's in something
on she was on a sitcom but i could be
wrong all right forget it
we uh so lesbian
was that what the l word was yeah okay
uh i got a pee for you mmm
really thick hot chocolate
whoa you ever go to like a bakery and
they and i'm like i didn't order a hot
chocolate concentrate yeah they just
hand it to you you're like i can't even
get through this it's so thick it's
cereal chocolate bar yeah it's like it's
like
they think it's like rich and
and you know but i was like hey man i
got hot chocolate so i could you know
move the rest of the day yeah that's a
good one wow that is a specific very
specific
it happened to me many years ago and we
walked by the store and gary goes i
[ __ ] hate a thick hot chocolate so do
i uh look at that yeah that's too much
what is this [ __ ] right here
you're making eating a brownie mix
basically it's like and it's fine for a
sip but you're going to hand me a whole
glass give me a shot i'll do a chocolate
shot yes i'm with you that's just fudge
[ __ ] that [ __ ] that dude no thank you
[ __ ] that
big hot dog a decent porn search but
not great to consume i'm with you it's
too thick it's supposed to be uh
refreshing and like you know homey and
comforting
you don't want to you want to drink it
with a spoon
yeah it's a pee have you got any wrecks
good peeve here's my wreck
you're not going to like it uh oh why
uh it's a little basic
take a walk was breaking ground
i'm saying it's on that level okay i
like it i like when you give a basic one
all right get yourself
a sponge
let's go that far off what are you
saying a lit roller
well maybe but i also have a hairy
girlfriend she's got hair all over the
tub and everything all over the [ __ ] you
hit yourself with a liberal you wouldn't
be surprised how much uh dna and hair
and follicle and all this dust on you
you'd be a new man after a lint roller
yeah i went on amazon i ordered like 10
of them
i think it's the cat though
don't you think matt he looks clean well
you look clean everything i think the
cat is doing the the most of the damage
here i mean because your comic you wear
dark colors a lot yes i mean that's true
telling you
get
oh that's cat only i'm talking this is
hair lint dandruff dust dander
everything i got a good dandruff cure oh
yeah yeah i've talked about it early on
on the show i think the the scraper you
have you put the shampoo in but then you
use that little head scrubber and it
really gets in there wait pull one of
those up what is it called it's like a
head scrubber head scrubber i know that
could be wrong that might be the name
yeah
head scrubber because i guess yeah those
things oh
i like it and i do this when the
shampoo's in yeah yeah and you rub it in
yeah you rub it in there you get in
there that's a key to a good scalp too
because uh gary goldman has beautiful
beautiful head of hair and i was like
what's the secret what's the key and he
goes activate the scalp
and i think that's what that does it
activates i think he told me he doesn't
shower a lot ah
that'd be great if you just told
different things to everyone he's just
going online
activate the scalp don't shout i think
we do over shower too oh my god we've
talked about that before too much yeah i
don't i don't wash my hair all the time
i got a brillo pad up here anyway but i
mean i had too much too much showering
yeah same i agree and you just take the
the oils out of your hair i think it's
supposed to have natural [ __ ] in there
look at that it's got beautiful
brown black locks luscious yeah look at
those locks and a decent clavicle if i
might add
but uh
yeah don't do it don't wash
i'd [ __ ] him in the ass
i feel like we can both win on that yeah
yeah gomez is great just play carnegie
hall oh
congrats to him
one of the great stand-ups amazing
writer
um
got me in at the comedy cellar thank you
gary
look at that yeah um
all right i got a wreck for you hit me
this one's even cheesier than yours all
right gonna be tough tough to beat that
little find inspiration that's my record
gary and i were in san francisco walking
around we're you know we're hitting a
little uh we hit mel's diner classic
little old school diner
the waiter was a fan of the podcast whoa
he goes he goes i i listen to we might
be drunk all the time i was like all
right we go to uh
we passed they're doing the leonard cohn
exhibition
who i know i drunk i don't remember this
episode this patreon cause i was
hammered where i said leonard cohen's
better than bob dylan i stand by it
brother but let me tell you another
thing i uh i got hulkamania on your ass
right there but uh we passed the leonard
cohn exhibition which i had seen at the
jewish museum here in new york it was
just happened to be showing there and i
said veda we got to go gary's not a big
leonard cohn guy and he was like this is
incredible really yeah a lot of it's
like it's like a
one of those uh geez what do you call
what's the word it's kind of like it's
immersive it's like the way the van gogh
thing they did that one but it's
snippets from interviews songs he says
so many wise things so uh you see that
you're like man this guy was cool
there's one part where he talked about
uh the poet lorca he said you know uh
the writer lorca he said
you know i didn't steal his his voice
but he gave me permission to find my own
like he talks about words that were that
inspired him like that's [ __ ] awesome
i loved it so yeah get inspired go out
and do good [ __ ] also i got a movie
wreck for you re-watch it it's streaming
on hbo max to great movie
collateral oh i love collateral
tom cruise as a villain which is awesome
yeah michael mann michael mann a great
movie uh maybe his best i mean insider i
love heat is a classic he's my third
probably after those two those two are
incredible um so good dude tom cruise is
great jamie foxx is always great always
great i love movies like that it's just
this kind of the whole thing takes out
in one night or two nights and it's just
this kind of uh
i don't say nothing story but it's not
like this big epic [ __ ] it's just
two dudes and their feelings and their
night and it's great
good dialogue yes tense you don't know
what's coming there's a lot of turns
where you're you're shocked yeah and i
you know i'd seen it before but i'm
watching with taylor and she hadn't and
watching it unfold for the second time
you're like oh this is pretty uh
this is pretty damn right in front of
your face but you still don't see it
coming what do you think the coyote
means
sorry the coyote there's one scene where
they pull up to a red light and a coyote
runs by it's like the only scene i don't
like yeah i didn't like the music they
played in that scene ever it felt very
out of place it felt like they were
shoving in symbolism force yeah i don't
know i think it comes from a book and my
friend who i saw it with told me he said
in the book
uh the tom cruise character is japanese
oh
he comes to america he has to pull off
these assassinations that's why he needs
a driver because he doesn't know his way
around ah
how do you like that
interesting okay
yeah great movie good wreck that movie
you know what you can tell a good movie
because this came on once in a green
room when i was in there with like four
guys and we're all talking and then two
minutes later we're all just glued in
it's it's gets you from the from the
jump yep and it's
it's surprising there's a lot of amazing
turns
uh it's just a great movie and uh i also
got to shout out one of our listeners
cause we we on the patreon we get uh
we get recommendations we get pet peeves
we get joke ideas we get drink ideas
they told me to watch the movie
something wild
with jeff daniels and melanie griffith
and a young ray liotta jonathan demi
film i watched it
i loved it is that the piano one no it's
uh basically about a yuppie jeff daniels
and he just meets this woman in a coffee
shop and something's off about her and
he likes her and she convinced them to
just go on a drive they end up [ __ ]
in a hotel room
and
they end up going to her high school
reunion and her her crazy ex-husband or
i guess still husband ray leota's there
and things get weird from there oh
interesting and it's it's it's a movie
with a lot of different uh
a lot of different tones it surprises
you that in tone shifts and uh
leota is incredible in it he's just so
fun it's fun he's scary and funny and we
it's it's a good movie it's i've never
heard of it i like movies where they're
hard to classify the genre yes
david lynch
it's kind of like that yeah which i
don't know lynch very well we talked
about this in the patreon norman and i
both are like we're not huge david lynch
guys and we know people are going to
[ __ ] hate that
i couldn't get into twin peaks yeah i
can hear that me neither too too eerie
for me like weird for weird sake yeah
campy too like it was a little campy
right
people whose opinions i really respect
love that show and yeah you know same
same just not my cup
but i'll check this out this looks like
a fun romp
yeah i'm into it yeah all right good
wrecks
what what lint roller i'll tell you that
what what do you got for a uh for a joke
oh for a [ __ ] all right um
this could be dumb this feels very
everything we've run on here right but i
haven't tried this on stage i ran it by
him earlier i don't know what he thought
but uh
i had a thing with the uh with the 18t
where you got to call in they [ __ ] up
my bill you know and you got to do
customer service and press one for
english press two for espanol press
three for billing and you gotta do the
whole thing and you're so mad and then
you finally get on with an operator
after 20 minutes and you just want to
yell at her but you also don't want to
lose her yeah and have her hang up on
you and be like sir you can't talk to me
that way so i think on these calls these
it calls they should hire a guy just to
yell at just a guy you can be like [ __ ]
you you piece of [ __ ] you don't know
what i'm going through and he's like i
understand sir i understand and then you
click back over to get your [ __ ] fixed
the punching bag yes
because you're so angry but you can't
let it out on them and you know i get
the lady of delta like sir this is not
my fault i'm just working the desk and
you're like i know but i missed my
flight because of you [ __ ] cut
and she's like this i didn't do it you
know but we need a person who you can
just chew out as part like somebody they
hire
and that guy gets paid really well yes
the human punching bag the guy who comes
on you go your mother raised a little
[ __ ] and he's like she did yeah i'm a
bad boy he takes it
yeah yeah i [ __ ] your wife he's like i
know she liked it or whatever it is
just just uh with that that wouldn't
make you feel better if he played along
if he didn't want it
like you know what i deserved that yeah
like this company sucks you work here
because you're a pu you're a [ __ ] you
piece of [ __ ] you never amount to
anything he's like ah it's hard because
a lot of the times like oh everything's
under staffed now because of cobalt it's
crazy people just stopped working a lot
of people were like i'm good [ __ ] [ __ ] a
job yeah uh i think they realize how
short life is and they were like yeah
i'll get by on some other [ __ ] you know
and that's why service jobs now like you
know we work at clubs and like how many
times you get a club and the show starts
like 45 minutes late because it's and
you can't even get mad cause you're like
it's understaffed
so so people so then these people who
are still at these jobs you're like oh
[ __ ] you need to have this job so
they're really not taking [ __ ] anymore
no they're really not yeah people know
and like nobody wants to go into an
office they all want to work from home
once you know what is
what can't be done you're not going in
you're not going to do that extra mile
because you're like
[ __ ] this i can get a job somewhere else
something about yeah about just cursing
them out too it's like it would be feel
so good and you'd want to stay with the
company like hey you're going with
sprint i'm staying with verizon they got
a they got a punching bag it's one of
the features press forward or let it all
out yes
i don't know where the turn is just just
some just some really weak world guy
like hello and you're like you [ __ ]
piece of [ __ ]
you know what you did right right like
sir can i help you with anything else
yeah can you roll me over to the uh to
bob so i can chew him out just something
where you can really let it out he's in
a [ __ ] suit like
yeah
yeah i don't know how to really package
it but i think it's a fun idea there's
something there yeah i don't know i
don't know what the turn is because it's
kind of just like yeah i mean
we have we get pent up all throughout
the day and then there's just nowhere to
put it yeah and these companies will
[ __ ] you over and you just got to like
accept it or cancel the company
or you know cancel your prescript or
subscription or whatever it is but it'd
be nice no nobody cares if you're like
i'll take my business elsewhere they're
like yeah i don't i'm not working on
commission here it's not enough yeah
exactly
yeah no it's it's about the cable
companies uh i called spectrum once i
was like i think i'm gonna cancel i
don't need cable anymore and they're
like whoa what can we do to keep you
here and i was like i don't know charged
me half and they were like okay we'll do
that
you can barter with your cable company
fun fact it's old school yeah i kind of
like that
try it yeah
do you have a tv cable or no i don't no
you just internet you mean i got
streaming and all that
oh yeah you guys have the thing yeah we
do
we got the chip
salaccus
is won't say the name of the service we
won't say anything mark mark really
floats through life with without a care
salaccus is terrified he's a father yeah
you're fine
but yeah all right so i'll noodle with
that i'll play with it i have a couple
ideas here's one uh
i was i went by a motel the other day
you know i was just walking by my motel
and i said we have hbo hmm
who's who's getting swayed by that in
this day and age like there's crap
there's crackheads and uh there's
needles in the parking lot but they're
like succession
yeah right right yeah
that's true
that's true i don't know if there's a
joke there but i saw that i was like
that's a weird uh maybe that's nothing
it's so antiquated you know it's like
saying hey we have hot water like
everybody's got hbo who gives a [ __ ]
and also i'm coming here to sleep i'm
not really here to watch uh the l word
or
six feet under why do you even have to
advertise that yeah i'm bringing it with
me right right
maybe maybe that's nothing like color tv
yeah no [ __ ]
is this anything there's a nba coach who
uh uh
who has cancer now and he's and i saw
one of the teams like post a thing of
support that said your battle is our uh
our battle coach and it's like but
that's but it's not really true
like you don't do that with anything
else i don't see a i don't see a guy in
like uh battle fatigue and go hey we're
in this [ __ ] together dude
you know what i mean yeah like it's like
you're not doing anything yeah you're
just [ __ ]
you're just pretending yeah so you can
support someone saying say this is our
battle
you're not going through chemo no you're
not going through radiation yeah you're
just saying that the coach should use it
oh it's our battle all right you take
this round of chemo i'll sit it out it's
our battle yeah you you're losing your
eyebrows and your hair too let's go yes
there you go
everybody's got a shave yeah hmm you
should at least have to get drunk i want
to see you at least vomiting if i'm
vomiting yeah right yeah
our battle is i'm [ __ ] off i got
nothing well maybe the team could use it
too like oh you lost three games in a
row well we all have cancer
that's not easy we're battling this here
i don't know i got nothing i'm [ __ ] i
either have jokes that are working or i
have jokes that are nothing yeah i don't
know if that uh
punching bag thing will go anywhere we
got another ad though let's do one more
ad hey we might be drunk is brought to
you by honey we all shop online and
we've all seen that promo code field
taunt us at checkout but thanks to honey
manually searching for coupon codes is a
thing of the past honey is the free
browser extension that scours the
internet for promo codes and applies the
best one it fits to your cart it's
simple when you check out the honey
button drops and all you have to do is
click apply coupons wait a few seconds
as honey searches for coupons it can
find for that site if honey finds a
working coupon we'll watch the process
prices drop look the holidays are coming
up
[ __ ]
holidays are coming up and uh you know
you got to get those gifts let's be
honest we're all going to shop online
might as well save a couple hundo with
honey throw that puppy in the search bar
tell them how to do it fatty if you
don't already have honey you could be
straight up missing on free savings it's
literally free and installs in a few
seconds and by getting it you'll be
doing yourself a solid and supporting
this podcast get honey for free at
joinhoney.com
drunk that's
joinhoney.com
drunk oh yeah
all right well
i feel like the the fact that we both
have like off bits is a good sign
because that means we're writing a ton
like i got some new stuff cooking on
stage same see i got a couple yeah a
couple it's tough man it's tough to
write new jokes and then it's like you
know i want to shoot something in the
next you know four or five months yeah
and it's kind of like all right new hour
right it's it seems like
it feels impossible right now to write a
new hour i know the idea of just
starting to scratch is just it's always
so painful daunting but it will it can
be done and where are we going you know
we got all the time in the world to
write new [ __ ] yeah dude
the fans are so great because uh the
drunks out there because i got like four
bits that we worked out on this in my
act and they're like i love seeing it on
the show then seeing it here on stage
it's so cool so they're part of the
process we i mean and more than just
this way and at the shows as well
because we're working it out there so we
appreciate you guys appreciate you guys
in the patreon patreon.com we might be
drunk pod you're the best uh we got a
lot of road dates coming up where are
you gonna be man uh this weekend i'm in
vancouver we got one show left we added
the show so this ticket's there then i'm
in new orleans at the howlin wolf first
place i ever got paid to do comedy and
then uh comedy castle in royal oak
michigan the pumpkin theater in atlanta
charlotte comedy zone i'm in toronto for
the dark comedy festival milwaukee
improv in december syracuse funny bone
ah my all-time nemesis kansas city
improv
and uh all kinds of good stuff coming up
so
tell a friend where are you gonna be
there samuel i'm we're a lot of the same
place i'll be at the charlotte uh comedy
zone as well uh i'll be uh miami improv
in december also i'll be in uh
wherever madison that's a fun one oh
addison yeah dallas uh that's uh in
december richmond coming up ruby's
coming up uh
a lot of other dates are coming
sacramento new york sold out pretty
quickly for the gramercy so so a bigger
venue is coming i hope you guys pay
attention uh i'm very excited yeah so
we'll talk about gramercy next time
hey man it was great i'm grateful uh for
the listeners and you guys on the road
it's it's been awesome yes thanks for
the the peeves the questions the wrecks
the drinks keep we got some new drinks
coming beer juice coming next week and
uh the paper planes are out there
everybody's talking people are loving
the paper planes we get tagged in a ton
of them huge those took off i don't know
why that one more than the others it's
such a good cocktail it's a great
cocktail great name and they look great
too they look great all right well thank
you guys we love you thank you keep on
drinking
[Music]
you